[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie man ganz einfach und superschnell
diese kinder schokoriegel creme
herstellen kann
wir benötigen 400 gramm kinderriegel die
habe ich schon klein geschnitten 400
milliliter schlagsahne und ein esslöffel
bacau die sahne wird einmal im kochtopf
aufgekocht bis die hochsteigt und wird
dann über die schokoriegel gegossen
anschließend kommt noch der kakao dazu
und das ganze mit fünf minuten lang
abgedeckt dann wird mit dem schneebesen
einmal alles schön verrührt bis sich die
zutaten miteinander verbunden haben
manchmal verbindet sich das ganze nicht
so gut wie in den kakao
dann könnt ihr einfach dem pürierstab
nehmen und das ganze eine minute lang
kurieren wie creme uns jetzt vollständig
abkühlen
ich gebe sie dafür in den
tiefkühlschrank und rührt dabei immer
wieder um und dann ist sie nach 30
minuten auch schon abgekühlt
dann gebe ich ihm eine küchenmaschine
ihr dürft aber auch gerne euer
handrührgerät benutzen die krim wird
jetzt dicke eineinhalb bis zwei minuten
lang gemixt dadurch wird sie auch etwas
ändert und anschließend gebe ich auch
viele für sonderfahrt hinzu und wir das
ganze noch so lange bis sie sich
verbunden hat
somit ist unsere kinder regelt er auch
schon fertig und kann sofort verwendet
werden
ich habe die creme jetzt als torten
füllung verwendet dafür habe ich sie
einfach in einen spritzbeutel gefüllt
und dekoriert damit meine torte
ihr könnt sie aber auch gemacht ihn
verwenden die mengenangaben reichen für
24 muffins aus oder aber für das
dekorieren einer 26 cm torte indem ihr
sie zweimal damit gefüllt
[Musik]
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und beim dekorieren reaktion
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
abonniert mich doch gerne kostenlos und
ich sagte zum nächsten mal auf die
thatcher